i've always wanted the top-tier women i
was never a top-tier guy
so that was where i was losing
and you had to look in the mirror and be
like yo bro you got to step your life
off i had to
and that's the part that hurts people
it's a hard thing to do of course i'm
telling you it's like so much easier to
blame and not take accountability she's
a [ __ ] my boss is an [ __ ] you're a
dick it's so much harder to be like
easier you're 30 pounds overweight
you're not actually working as hard as
you could you're not hitting the gym
you're actually kind of a dick you like
you're you're you're negative like it's
so much harder to do that it's so much
easier to blame shift 100 adam
and to me that is the radical
accountability starts off with is and
when i got radical i realized
what am i talking about
why why would
that kind of woman want me
and so there's this idea
in the world of men
where
because i am me i actually get the top
tier women but
that's not true in anything in life
because i am me i should be the number
one basketball player in the nba right
because i am me i should be the number
one singer in the world there's nothing
in life where just maybe in your mom's
world you can be you and be the king of
the planet maybe in the world of
participation trophies you can just show
up and get a reward not how life works
life you have to work for what you want
you have to ask yourself what do i want
do i do i want to be financially
chilling like adam well i got to do the
work that men who financially children
do
and so to me
it got me to that point where i realized
in the past i was an average a little
above average guy but i wanted top notch
adam i was i'm the pickiest guy
i'm the piggiest
pornography is poison but back when i
used to watch porn i would have to go to
seven i'd be on page 17 so i found the
one i liked that's how picky i was
there's a lot of time there i've been
going through a lot of time because i
was so picky and so to me i acknowledged
it was my fault
so what what changed
what changed
what made you say all right like what
did you actually step by step do and say
all right let me look in the mirror give
some accountability what changed true
did you get wealthier smarter better
looking in shape like what did you
actually have so what did what did i do
or what what was the light switch yeah
the light switch happened aha moment and
then true actually
yeah i moved to houston because of a
girl
i have theories i have so many theories
i spent 10 years i have a book of
theories and i test out i'm like a
doctor who does all the experiments on
himself so i don't tell any man to do
anything i haven't done myself had a
theory there was a girl i really liked
she was into me had a theory to make her
into me i tested it out i moved to
houston obviously it never works
don't move because of a girl but then i
but then i realized that's when it
dawned on me i was like yo
look at
where you're at
you did all this for a girl but what did
you do for yourself
damn powerful
what did you do for yourself how were
you different were you better or where
you were to be just the same
and i realized okay
let me look at the kind of women that i
want
who are they married to
what kind of men do they like and let me
be honest
about where i'm at
so hard to do i was in houston i was
sleeping on the couch
with my friend's place
ladies leave him on the couch not even
not let me tell you the story like i was
literally sleeping on the couch you
moved to houston for her you couldn't
even stay at her place of course you
won't let me stay out of her place what
the heck let me get going
like he wouldn't let me in there
but you were dating her no oh what
that's what i'm saying i test everything
i'm a crazy guy
you moved there because you liked a girl
yes you weren't even dating her no
that's [ __ ]
i'm telling you okay hey man you had to
hit rock bottom sleeping on the counter
to figure it out that's why guys relate
to me because i'm never a guy talking
about i banged 100 chicks i did all this
i was a guy at rock bottom who just like
most guys was struggling who was upset
who cried at night over girls and i
learned how to make myself better that
was my rock bottom point what did i do
yeah the first thing i realized
was as a man
first things first is presentation
i'm a visual person i like women who
look a certain way so are most men so
are most men shout out to the men so man
you got to realize if you like a woman
who looks a certain way if you and her
took a picture together do you guys
match
do you guys match does it make it
doesn't even make any sense because she
if she looks a certain way physically
she a sort of mating would probably want
someone who looks a certain way
physically as well and physically as a
man doesn't also necessarily mean the
face it can mean the clothes it can mean
the style it can mean your mannerisms
the confidence all these different
things so i realized i as my as a man
have not got those things situated which
is what got me into style
was what got me into suits because i
tell men all the time you want to feel
like what it's like to get plastic
surgery as a like a woman's effect put
on a well-tailored suit and live life
right well they say
that to a man the hottest thing a woman
can wear is lingerie yes and to a woman
the hottest thing a man can wear is a
fresh shirt i'm telling you are you
doing it
david
davey dollars
hot track suit
and so
i have so many stories about suits we'll
have time for it so styling yeah i
realized okay styling i had to work on
so then there was things about
internally as a man i was not on my
purpose i spent most of my whole focus
was to get a woman instead of becoming
the best man that god made me to be so
instead of spending all day long waiting
for a text back instead of spending all
day long swiping on tinder or swiping on
hinge i say you know what let me put all
my time and energy into building my
business
and then then what i would do is with my
remaining time
i would spend it dating know what that
does for 99 percent of men it makes you
less needy
off that alone will make you less needy
right because now
you actually have things to do when you
text a woman and she don't text you back
sometimes she's not into most of the
time she's not interested but sometimes
she's actually doing stuff the reason
why you're waiting for a text back
because you have you're not doing
anything yeah and so to me as a man
you're sitting around watching your
phone and you're gonna
we've all been there we've all been
there i've been there now when you're
freaking busy and you're accomplishing
thing and you're succeeding you're like
i forgot to even text her exactly i
don't even remember if she texted
exactly telling you that happens exactly
so then i started building the
my purpose and then i started to realize
okay what were some of the things that
turned women off for me the neediness to
wanting too much time and i started
working on those things
getting back in my best shape i played
college football i went vegan for a
couple years i lost 20 something pounds
i became like skeletor like the guy from
nightmare before christmas i got back in
the gym
i just started building like literally
building pieces learning from other guys
oh wow he did this he does that and i
started improving it bit by bit piece by
piece got my own place stopped living
with seven guys sometimes it's okay
nothing wrong with it to save money yeah
but if you're to want a relationship
it's hard two things i learned it's hard
to always
tell her to come over when there's seven
other guys you live yeah
and it's also hard as a man
to always go to her place because now
it's this psychological shift where now
you're always coming to her i call it
home court advantage
what do you think
why do you think that you know
playoffs you know you want game seven
at home and you see this i didn't learn
this in a book me and adam i'm talking
about these ideas adam related because
we went through experience
when men go out into life
we live life we learn these things from
experience men don't got to learn from
experience so all these little things
from improving myself style-wise getting
back into into the gym
then also having other guys with me
because one thing that i've told people
all the time is that when you see in a
very attractive group of girls
yeah what you don't realize is they're
not as hot as you think they are
sometimes
it's just that there's an eight there's
a seven there's a nine there's a six
there's a like you're just adding them
all up is that what you're saying it's
not it's that but it's like
five sevens because there's no weak link
yeah you think they're all nines ah
gotcha you know what i mean and so what
i realized is as a man you have strength
in in community and togetherness it's
one thing for me to go out wearing a
suit uh that's a weird guy wearing a
suit yeah depending on how you rock it
when the homies roll out with the suits
it's a rabbit it's a wrap yeah it's a
wrap adam it's a whole new world so i
learned it's also the power of community
of having other guys because that that
creates suited up bro i'm trying to tell
you